you had to be out of your mind watching
ucla
on that run that was unbelievable uh
yeah i was so happy for for for cronin
and that whole
that whole squad i was actually talking
about them last night and how great is
this going to be for the program
moving forward hopefully we can head
back to that uh
you know being prominent in in men's
basketball
uh and across the board for ucla
athletics and it's just a special thing
for such a storied
story university and story program so
i'm i'm really excited to see
uh you know where they're gonna end up
to start the season but more importantly
you know next march when it comes time
again if they can back up what they did
with their final four run
it's just amazing how you watch a team
sort of uh gain confidence and then gain
steam
and then gain an error an aura of
invincibility
yeah what's the closest you've ever been
to that uh obviously we know what
happened with the cavs but
any other moment or could you say that
equates to that too
yeah i mean i think it's really easy to
say the the the 2012
olympic team but as far as you know i
say all the time after
after our 2016 championship that 16 1617
team the following year i i truly
believe that
that that was our um
not only most powerful team but most
together most feeling of like you said
that
invincible every time we we stepped on
the floor we knew we were gonna get
everybody's best shot but we
we were used to that we we knew that
every single night in those 82 nights
uh of the regular season and then
heading into the playoffs that that was
going to condition us to to really play
at a very very high level when the time
came and there was nothing that we
hadn't seen
from from previous years but that team
was so together we have so much talent
so many great veterans
uh and with kyrie lebron and myself and
the the supporting
uh staff and and everybody involved and
players were
were just amazing and that feeling of
togetherness and
uh you know playing an extremely high
level was just there so
um what did you make kevin love of
lebron
saying he doesn't know if he'll ever be
a hundred percent again
due to his high ankle sprain what did
you make of that that comment yeah i
mean i i think
lebron is somebody that and moving
forward out of this has an extremely uh
high threshold and i've seen the the
work that he puts in a lot of people
don't get to pull back that curtain
right and see what's behind it and how
hard that he works um and that could be
you know on the court whether it be in
the the weight room or
you know just working on his overall
body and how much he spends uh
time-wise and money-wise on that so i
think
uh you know in in his age and his how
many years and miles he has under him
that
i i don't know if that will that will
truly slow him down but i do think that
there's something to be said for
you know these playing games and teams
for example
like a uh brooklyn who has nagging
injuries with kd
has nagging injuries with uh harden
who's coming back from from an injury
not too long ago and then
being able to have this eight to ten
days of practice time of being on the
floor together of resting those injuries
and potentially getting back to uh if
not 100
close to it so i i think plan the
playing game for
for the lakers especially going against
a team with
you know who's essentially playing like
the best player on the planet right now
and
uh you know who's you know could win mvp
uh you know despite the odds that were
against them and steph curry that
you know that's that's a little bit you
know tougher that's going to wear on
them and they they came off
you know six games in the finals and an
unprecedented you know shortest
offseason ever
ever shortest offseason for any major
sport
so i think all that really factors in
and the time off
and and you know getting a rhythm we
always talk about that with somebody
coming back from injury and getting
their legs underneath them and
and a d is is is really the same way
he's not you know he's enough games back
to where he's starting to look like
himself but
i think tonight will be you know very
telling in that
then obviously it would be crucial for
the lakers to just one and done this
playing tournament and then get some
time off before their first round series
against the suns and that would be a
fun series to watch no doubt about it
kevin love here on the rich eisen show
who is your mvp i'd love to get your
player perspective and your keen
insight uh also of the basketball
knowledge who who is your 20 20 2021 mvp
yeah i mean it's really hard not to say
the joker
i mean yoga just been so unbelievable
this year um you know i
i've had a couple seasons where i've
been able to put up you know being the
top five in scoring and then you know
top
five in rebounding but the fact that
he's been able to
not only do that but you know have eight
plus assists a night
is just truly special and he's proved it
has it didn't miss the games like joelle
i mean joel would have been right there
at the very top
i still think he's in very likely the
top three
and then it's really hard not to put
steph uh
at the very top if not number two with
with all that he's done in a historic
run that he's had personally and and
playing his team that a lot of people
didn't think were going to make it into
the playoffs
into the play in game and just playing
at a
almost an all-time high level if you
compare the stats to
um you know his 2016 2015-16 season
where he was the unanimous
mvp in that 73-9 season so
i i i'm not going to say it's a toss-up
between the two because i still think
the joker is
very likely the mvp but i would have
absolutely
uh no problem and no pushback with with
putting
uh i know he'll get a a fair share of
votes as well in in steph curry uh and
then probably
you know 2a and 2b are definitely with
embiid especially with
um you know what he's been able to do on
both sides of the ball
as well as you know getting them into
the first seed uh with his team and and
i think doc
rivers and and everybody there has done
a great job of putting them uh
in that position so the best team you
saw
whether you were active or not this year
that you think's got the best shot here
what do you think yeah i mean it's it's
so hard to
because you know i was i was talking to
somebody about this as far as you know
the western conference goes i don't know
if we've ever seen the firepower quite
like
uh the teams that that we saw especially
uh you know those those those finals
runs but you know i mentioned that 16-17
team that we had
from uh you know it's well known a 73-9
team in the warriors ads
you know kevin durant and mvp went on to
be you know two
two-time finals mvp so that that's the
most firepower i believe we've ever seen
in this league in the western conference
maybe ever and then
you know with brooklyn you add uh you
know
kyrie and kd and then james harden so i
don't know
if in the eastern conference we've we've
quite seen that before so i don't know
if those guys are all healthy and
clicking i don't know how you stop that
it's such a pace in space league
a lot of teams can can you know outscore
one another but i just don't know if
we've seen them
enough on the court together to to truly
get a grasp on on
truly how how great they can be but on
paper they certainly look
uh like the best team but i i i would
say
if they're really clicking at a high
level that it's
it's you know almost i wouldn't say an
easy answer but but natural to
to pick them as uh one of the favors if
not the favorites
especially in that eastern conference
kevin love two-time nba
uh all-nba team five-time all-star uh
2016
nba champion current cleveland cavalier
right here on the rich eisen show the
piece that you wrote the first person
piece i believe for the players tribune
on the subject matter uh of mental
health awareness certainly caught my eye
um and now uh i'm thrilled to have you
here now to discuss this very important
subject matter because
you know there's no caste there's no
crutch there's no physical
um identification that somebody is
hurting
when it comes to mental health awareness
uh i'll give you the floor on what
you're up to
and what you want to people to know on
this subject matter kevin
no it's i mean as we all know now i
think you know in the last
12 to 14 months especially through this
pandemic and
with social injustice uh being brought
to the forefront of conversation
um for me i would say like the wildfires
out west that
took so many people out of their homes
either burned down the business or
you know people that lost everything uh
you know was
was extremely tough for so many people
there uh
you know and how it affected the
environment and then on top of that we
had the election and then everything
that came after that so just
coming out of this time i believe that
the mental health conversation has come
to the forefront
and you know there's such a stigma
around mental health issues and so many
people
suffer in silence don't know how to get
started uh so obviously
you know it's impera i mean paramount
that we provide resources so with
with general mind it's it's you know
allows you to see how your genes
affect your mental wellness in your
mental health and it's just an
unbelievable expert starting starting
point excuse me
for your mental health journey and they
provide you information
actionable steps on the path to both
physical and emotional wellness it's
really
uh you know a special thing to to see
and mental health is is just such a a
function
of four things and that's genetics
environment
lifestyle experiences and really we've
only had access to three of the four of
those things but
because of gender mind we've been able
to finally understand how your genes
affect your mental health and that could
be from anybody that can be from you
know your your
grandparents all the way to your
grandchildren and and understanding that
you know we can better understand your
predisposition and give you the tools
you know overcome obstacles so it's a
it's a special tool for people and like
i said the resources coming out of this
time
will be vast and this is one of the
truly great ones yeah
mentalhealthmap.com
and use the code of kevinmhm
for a mental health map to get 25 off
your own general mind
mental health map to try and figure that
stuff out do you
deal with this stuff during the season
or just you wake up and you're like
feeling off or something like that like
can you
express that because it's imp it's so
important to hear it from somebody
like yourself who is successful in
pretty much everything that you do
um and you know we live in an instagram
world as well and we see
your life and instagram and it looks
phenomenal but some you know
we we we've had so many athletes come on
here and talk about mental health
awareness and it it it connects with so
many of the listeners and viewers of
this show because everybody does know
somebody
what's your experience with it kevin
yeah i mean i think
you know to your point and to piggyback
off of that i mean it's such a
we live in such a curated um
world as far as social platforms and
social media where
it can be extremely misleading to
to you know how people are actually
feeling uh in their lives and and the
struggles that they have i mean it's a
it's i think it's a beautiful thing i
wouldn't be here in speaking about this
without demar derozan and his
um you know willingness to to share his
depression dak prescott same thing
um i even mentioned paul george with
within the bubble and i see i think you
see that
across uh both men's and and and women's
sports at the highest level
and it's a beautiful thing to to share
with people
and understanding this thing doesn't
discriminate i mean success is
is truly not immune to depression and
um people continue to speak about it and
breaking down that
stigma and and providing a language for
for others to express themselves and
come out of the shadows is truly
important and to answer your first
question yeah i mean this is something
that i live with every single day i've
had to
change my relationship with in a major
way whether it be my anxiety
uh you know or my depression and just
you know understanding there's no
quick fix for this and that's why you
know even speaking about gender mind is
so important just
understanding how these different things
um you know affect you
every single day and how you can truly
you know
have an action plan and many resources
out there that that are that are
affordable for people to to start this
journey especially coming out of this
time because it's going to be so needed
kevin i appreciate the time uh hopefully
we can do this more often
uh i hope you know uh enjoy you know
hearing you talk and i enjoy what you
have to say and obviously what you do on
the court
um you had a nice finish to the season
as well
um and and i i assume that you're you're
you've got nothing but uh
upside in front of you there in
cleveland i'm sure you feel the same way
yes sir i appreciate you having me on
rich thanks for the call thanks for the
call kevin that's kevin love everybody
at kevin love on twitter and instagram